what is your sign say sir please do my  fan correction did you send us one all  right what's that you're a man I don't  know when you're handing me a flash  drive  you want me to plug that right into my  computer  and then be arrested for crazy German  pornography I cannot take that from you  but we we have them all loved so we'll  research it we'll find it what's your  name I know but we don't do all of them  we get a lot of submissions you're like  a guy that's like I bought this lottery  ticket where's my money we will look I  will look back into what is your name  sir Tony do you want to make our search  a little easier I'm seeing a lot of  tapes come in you're the billions Conan  fan I will find you when we look at your  tape okay all right but I am NOT not  taking that flash drive  [Applause]  [Music]  you